nuevo roce diplomático para francia el
portavoz del gobierno gabriela tal
afirmó este lunes que francia endurecerá
las condiciones para la obtención de
visas a ciudadanos de marruecos argelia
y túnez esto en respuesta a la falta de
colaboración de dichos estados a la hora
de lidiar con el retorno de los
migrantes que entraron a francia de
manera ilegal desde esos países sin
decisión es una decisión drástica una
decisión sin precedentes pero es una
decisión necesaria porque algunos países
se niegan a recuperar a sus nacionales
ciudadanos que no queremos y no podemos
mantener el portavoz confirmó la
información de europa uno de una futura
caída del 50% de los visados a
nacionales marroquíes y de argelia un 33
por ciento en el caso de túnez en la
oposición las reacciones han sido
dispares en la derecha los republicanos
apoyan la medida pero critican que llega
demasiado tarde y desde la izquierda al
partido la francia en su milla acusa al
gobierno de asimilar el discurso de la
extrema derecha basta de la extremo
derechización de la sociedad comencemos
a hablar de los temas que realmente
importan en la vida de los franceses el
poder adquisitivo la congelación de los
precios la cuestión medioambiental en
los países afectados la noticia ha sido
recibida con sorpresa el ministro de
exteriores marroquí aseguró que el
problema es francés pues no pueden
demostrar la nacionalidad de los
deportados este joven muestra también su
preocupación por las consecuencias que
la medida pueda tener sobre la juventud
con francia no debería olvidar que cada
año hay muchos estudiantes que van a
francia a completar sus estudios
la decisión del gobierno de manuel
macrón se da a pocos meses de las
elecciones presidenciales una campaña en
la que el tema migratorio será uno de
los ejes centrales la candidata de
extrema derecha marine lepén ha
propuesto un referendo para
constitucionalizar el control migratorio